the pandemic is of course dramatically
changing our everyday lives as we
continue our series on the new normal we
look at how those changes will affect
the way we work socialize learn and vote
this week many voters in two states cast
their ballots by mail at O'Keefe shows
us how the push to make voting safer
while also safeguarding election
integrity the coronavirus means the days
of long lines of voters and libraries or
gymnasiums could be over at least
temporarily as states decide instead to
let more people vote by mail this is not
what any of us had envisioned months ago
for how we wanted to run this election
voters in Ohio in parts of Maryland
headed to the polls on Tuesday or drop
their ballot in the mail officials made
the change as they tried to balance
public health with participatory
democracy I have two main priorities
keeping Marylanders safe and protecting
their constitutional right to vote polls
show a majority of Americans now support
expanding the vote by mail option we
think it's a health issue at this point
the idea I think that mail-in voting is
a terrible thing
the corona virus has completely
scrambled the 2020 campaign calendar
only three states and the District of
Columbia are holding primaries is
scheduled every other state has either
postponed contests or expanded to a vote
by mail system and this week New York
for the first time canceled its
presidential primary set for June I've
seen lines of people on television
voting in other states as is totally
nonsensical a recent nonpartisan study
estimates it cost as much as 1.4 billion
dollars to ensure all voters have access
to mail-in ballots by November
proponents point to what happened with
the Wisconsin primary this month to
justify potential costs officials this
week said at least 52 people who voted
or worked the polls on April 7th have
tested positive for coronavirus it's
unclear how they got sick but the cases
confirm the fears of those who wanted to
delay the primary we could have moved to
an all-male in elec
and at the same time we could have
protected the integrity of the election
for CBS this morning I met O'Keefe in
Washington